one of the few adults we know in the
foreign policy realm is tulsi gabbard
the former member of congress from
hawaii we're happy to have her join us
tonight congressman thanks so much for
coming on so it's without even going
into what they told us was russian
disinformation is actually true how
concerned are you that taurian newland
who's overseeing this war
has just admitted there are unsecured
bio agents dangerous bio agents in
ukraine
i'm extremely concerned as should be
every american and everyone in the world
uh the seriousness of this situation
really can't be overstated first of all
she didn't say no when she was asked by
marco rubio about there being biological
or chemical weapons in ukraine so uh if
if there were or are obviously that
would be a a violation of the biological
weapons convention uh number two
she they're they're categorically been
trying to hide this as you've laid out
very very well and then once they were
found out rather than saying hey you
know what this is a critical an
emergency it's a crisis we have these
pathogens in the midst of a war zone not
just in one location but between 20 and
30 labs in ukraine we've this is a
global crisis we're going to take action
immediately this is how a responsible
leader
would react given the crisis of this
moment but instead what did they do
her response to to senator rubio was
immediately start pointing fingers we're
going to preemptively start the blame
game should anything happen
to these pathogens and and who knows
what is going on in these labs before
anything bad happens just say you know
what it's the bad guys it's the bad guys
who are responsible for this it's i it
is the height of irresponsibility their
response to this the fact that they're
covering it up the fact that they aren't
doing really what needs to be done
because if unless this war in ukraine
ends right now ends tonight
we face a very real certainty that one
or more of these labs will be
compromised will be breached and it
won't just be the people of ukraine who
are impacted we could face another
global crisis when you look at a
pathogen that could be released we just
went through this with kovid
we can't have forgotten this already
and once again
agencies in the us government without
our knowledge are secretly funding
research that you know imperils the
world and no one is ever punished for it
so speaking of no one ever punished we i
wanted to get reaction to this 27
foreign policy heavyweights
just signed an open letter calling for
what they call a quote limited no-fly
zone over ukraine some of the people who
signed it include former nato allied
supreme commander phil breedlove u.s
ambassador ukraine william taylor former
u.s ambassador nato kurt volcker etc etc
what exactly are they proposing and is
it a wise idea do you think
uh it is not just just one last thing on
on the danger of these these labs that
the us is funding not only in ukraine
and around the world they need to be
shut down immediately they need to be
shut down immediately they are insecure
they are posing a threat to the world
they need to be shut down immediately uh
on on the no-fly zone that's being uh
proposed and encouraged by these
so-called foreign policy experts
look they're they're trying to act tough
tucker they're trying to say you know
we've got to do something and i i get it
there is so much suffering that we're
seeing on our televisions all day and
all night and and i get that the
american people are frustrated because
we want to see this end
instead of our leaders doing the
responsible thing and saying okay let's
do our best to try to facilitate a
negotiated outcome to actually end this
conflict a window of opportunity that
president zielinski opened up you know
what just 24 36 hours ago instead of
doing that they're focused on hey let's
just do something look tough enact a
no-fly zone which would not help the
ukrainian people it would make things
worse it's not going to help the
american people it'll make things worse
it'll drastically escalate this crisis
and put our pilots directly against
russian pilots putting us in conflict at
war with russia the other nuclear armed
power pushing us shoving us towards this
brink of of nuclear catastrophe and
nuclear war that that would destroy the
world
yeah and ukraine you know save ukraine
by destroying ukraine
exactly and
iraq libya syria the list goes on and on
we've got to learn from these lessons
and and stop this madness
so we're just getting this from the
state department this is a tweet and i
want to i'm reading this call but i want
to run it by you the united states does
not have chemical or biological weapons
labs in ukraine
then they put up a graphic that read the
us is in full compliance with its
obligations under the biological weapons
convention does not develop or possess
biological weapons anywhere i can see
about four holes in that so if you were
i mean so they're telling us they don't
own any bio labs in ukraine i don't
remember i mean one of the tells to
lying is when you answer a question no
one asked i don't think anyone's
suggesting this government owns bio labs
there right
that's right
that's right but but you pointed to
evidence and we've seen through
different parts of the world we saw in
china
how the u.s is funding this research or
these labs to the tune of hundreds
around the world
why
that question has never been asked or
answered by them say why why is it why
why is this research something that that
is so critical not done in secure labs
within the united states
why is this research being outsourced
there are so many different questions
here and all of it points back to really
the risk that this is posing again this
is something that is fresh in our
memories and if if they have nothing to
hide why are they trying so hard to hide
it well they said well they've already
admitted it i mean the under secretary
of state and the secretary of state just
admitted it under oath yesterday so like
let's let's not let them pretend that
this is like
we're carrying putin's water again or
they're such liars
i appreciate having an honest person on
the show with such a relief tulsi
gabbard thank you
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else